- Hey everyone, hope you're
having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens, I'm
in Colombo, Sri Lanka.
And I'm with the Best
of Sri Lanka Food Tour,
The Hungry Tourist.
Today, we are gonna start off,
we're in Pettah, in the
busy market area of Colombo.
We're going to start off for lunch,
then we're going to drive to Weligama
which is in the south of Sri Lanka.
And that's on the beach.
We're gonna have dinner on the beach.
Not totally sure all
we're going to do today,
but I'm going to share it
with you in this video.
And we just arrived for lunch.
(lively guitar music)
- [Mark] Hello!
- Hi friend, I really like you, you know.
I'm always following you
- [Mark] Thank you very much.
- Jaffna street food,
so I'm from up north.
- [Mark] Oh, awesome, okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah so that's where
you get the different sort of cuisine.
You'd like to see the kitchen also?
- [Mark] Sure, we could, yes, yes.
(restaurant chatter)
- This a restaurant that serves Northern
Sri Lankan food, Jaffna, from Jaffna food.
So we came into the restaurant,
it's a very local spot.
They have all the curries in the front.
There's a crab curry, there's
chicken, there's cuttle fish.
Oh, it smells incredibly good.
- This one is fish
- [Mark] You come to eat here often?
(laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah!
(lively guitar music)
(speaking Sri Lankan)
- [Man In Dark Blue Shirt] Carrot.
- I think maybe more of
a kitchen is up here.
Steps are a little narrow
so be careful of your step.
Smells incredible up here.
(spoon mixing)
(sizzling)
(ladle tapping)
- [Mark] I gotta, I gotta go again, ooh!
(sizzling and banging)
(upbeat music)
(sizzling)
(spoon mixing)
- Will do!
This is some serious omelet making skills.
And some serious egg beating skills.
(upbeat guitar music)
- [Mark] Spicy one?
- [Uchith] Yeah, you can try it.
- [Mark] Okay
(Uchith laughs)
- Okay, all of us are trying
the extra spicy omelet.
Oh.
Wow, its' amazing.
It's so salty.
Oh, man, oh, there's so much
like, chili paste in there.
That's amazing.
(restaurant chatter)
It's all served on a banana leaf.
You get rice, you get the
different curries, you get dahl.
Oh wow.
- This is prawns, and this calamari.
Spicy one, okay?
- [Mark] Thank you!
- Mm!
- You want spicy?
- Yes.
(upbeat music)
- [Mark] Those are blue crabs, mm?
- Yes the blue and blue (mumbles)
- [Mark] Okay, thank you.
(upbeat music)
- I got red rice, they dish you the dahl,
they dish you the different
curries, the achar.
I got a spicy omelet, there's crab curry,
there's prawns curry, there's cuttle fish.
It's all here, it's all
served on a banana leaf.
Gonna set this camera down.
Another extra spicy
omelet but what you can do
you can mix in the mix with your fingers.
Oh.
- [Server] Mutton?
Carrots and, yes please, sure.
- Mutton?
- [Server] Mutton.
- Oh, thank you.
Oh, awesome, mutton!
Mutton, oh yeah.
- What I learned about this place is
is people don't have a easy life.
Only point of comfort in their
lives is when they sit down to eat.
So they make the most out of it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Even with no money
and no nothing they put,
they create genius, genius food.
Just to create this magical moments
of comfort in their life.
- [Mark] Okay, mutton curry,
dump this on the rice.
Ho ho ho ho ho ho!
These little guys.
Okay now we have a complete meal set.
You can even see the curry leaves in here.
The mutton curry mixed in.
- [David] Oh yeah, thank the Lord.
(upbeat guitar music)
Oh, oh (mumbles), oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] Gonna try the omelet,
again another extra spicy.
There's chili paste in
it and there's chilies.
Mix that with the mutton.
- [Mark] Mm, oh that omelet with
the mutton curry sauce, it's amazing.
For the crab, I'm gonna
break this crab in half here.
Oh, it's so juicy and
oh there's so much curry
sauce inside of it.
Oh wow.
Spin it up.
- [David] Sounds like you're crazy.
- Oh.
Oh it's so flavorful.
The crab is sweet, that crab is awesome.
I haven't made it there yet.
- [Mark] The meat just flows out
and then that curry sauce is awesome.
The curry leaves in there.
- [Mark] Okay, I'm gonna
dig into that fish now.
Oh, it's so crispy.
Mix in with the curry, mix
in with the, everything.
This is one of those meals
that you wanna throw down.
You would just like
focus on the food and you
can't even speak during this meal.
- [Mark] Ending with a drink now.
Mm!
It's a little bit sour and
oh ho it's kinda like mustardy.
Almost mustardy but
sour, like a sour drink.
It's really good.
Thank you so much, man,
that was an amazing meal.
Thank you, thank you.
Wow just like waddling,
waddling out of here.
That was amazing, amazing meal.
The flavors, the spices.
Sinan, how was that dude?
- Yeah, it was amazing man.
I loved it!
[Mark] Such a good meal.
Confused, I don't even remember
where I am after that meal.
(chuckles)
Okay, but yeah, we are moving on now.
We're driving to Weligama,
which is in the south.
It's about a two and a
half hour drive to the
south of Sri Lanka and
we are on our way now.
Belly very full and very happy.
(upbeat music)
- [Mark] Thank you.
Alright!
It's about a two and a half
hour drive, time to take a nap
(whispers) Micah's already sleeping.
(upbeat acoustic guitar music)
- [Mark] Okay.
(laughs)
- [Mark] Yes!
- [Ying Wiens] Yes!
- [Mark] This is awesome.
- [Man] Highway traffic.
- [Mark] Oh yes!
- They're not selling it, but
like, we'll get it from them.
- [Mark] Oh yes!
- Like durian?
- [Mark] I love durian.
- Really?
- [Mark] The best.
- [Durian Vendor] Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] So we were driving tasked to,
we're almost to Weligama actually,
or maybe we are in Weligama but
we saw a truck selling local durian.
And the truck was actually,
like, they were stuck.
I think the truck was broken down but they
they waited for us, we pulled them over.
They waited for us, they're
about to get some durian.
They're about to,
they're not selling them,
but for us they decided
to make an exception.
And you can smell'em.
I'm in the right van with the Malaysians.
- Nammit.
The Thais
- Nagun!
- [Mark] and Ruzaina.
- Durian!
- [Mark] Oh it smells so good.
(motors running)
(vehicles honking)
- [Ben] Oh.
Can we just get him to follow
us back to the hotel then?
- [Mark] Yes!
(laughs)
- [Ruzaina] You can buy then!
- [Ying] (speaking Thai)
Micah
how's that?
- Mm!
(laughs)
- [Mark] Yes!
Our first bite of Sri Lankan durian.
Ho ho ho ho ho.
- [Mark] It's so creamy, so buttery,
just a hint of bitterness.
- Ruzaina, it's amazing, yeah?
- It's so good, right?
I don't know how people
don't like to eat this
because it's so good.
- [Mark] Unbelievable.
It's so creamy, mm.
- [Mark] I think they're
negotiating to buy an
entire basket of durian to
bring back to the hotel.
Or to bring outside of the hotel.
But, it's good, it's really, really good.
And we're having one
more as we stand here.
(upbeat acoustic guitar music)
- [Ben] Take video, yeah.
- [Mark] It's always good
to have impromptu durian.
Mm, and every one we've tried,
I think we've had about
four standing here.
They all taste different.
They're all different sweetnesses,
all different, like, complexities.
This one is less sweet
and not quite like as flavorful actually.
Still good though.
I think we're finished
here, we got some durians
to bring back for the others as well.
- [Ying] Okay!
(Micah speaking Thai with Ying)
- [Mark] Oh, oh yeah, we
want soursop so bad too.
More durian. (laughs)
We just made it down
the road like 100 meters
and there's another fruit stall.
Oh man, that's a beautiful fruit.
There's bananas, there's more durian.
There's rambutan, there's star fruit.
There's tomotoes, there's pineapples.
There's, aw, soursop!
We need to get some soursop!
- My name Michael.
- [Mark] Wow, cool!
- Micah, very cool.
- [Mark] Cool, cool!
- [Michael] Nice name!
- [Mark] Thank you very much.
- [Mark] You have wood apple today?
Wood apple.
- Yes, yes, everything.
I have everything for.
- [Mark] Oh there's wood apple
over there, okay.
- [Mark] Thank you, mango.
No, is that mango?
Yeah.
Wow it tastes like honey.
- [Mark] It's like the
sweetest mango you'll ever have
Wow
- It's so delicious
- [Mark] It's so sweet!
Like, unbelievable.
It's almost like sweet and starchy.
- [Ben] Jack fruit.
- The right one
- [Ben] Yep!
- [Ruzaina] May one to me.
(speaking Sri Lankan)
- [Mark] I try this one?
Okay this is the soursop.
Mm, oh soursop is awesome.
Beautifully sour but like,
creamy like, milky sourness.
Round two, durian?
(motorbike passing)
- [Michael] Nice one.
- [Mark] Okay, thank you very much.
Well we had to try another
durian, this is a smaller one.
- Mm
- Mm!
- Mm.
- Yes (laughs)
- This is way better.
- I'm eating so (laughs)
- They're getting better.
Upgrading every round with stuff.
They're getting better.
- Just getting some grunts.
- Mm.
- There's no seeds!
- Oh yeah, oh ho ho ho wow.
- Mm.
- Oh this one is amazing.
Oh that's the taste right there.
The bitterness,
- [Ben] Yeah.
- slightly fermented, and nutty.
Oh man, yeah that one, okay.
- [Mark] That's the taste right there.
This one is even better.
- [Ben] I think we need another, one more.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I think we need
- Can we get one more?
- [Mark] Another one of these.
- Oh my God!
- This is why I'm hanging out with
the Malaysians, Ben and Bobby.
(laughs together)
- One Sri Lankan, Malaysian
- Whenever you're eating durian you'll
always hear, "I need another one."
- [Ben] Yeah.
(upbeat acoustic guitar music)
- [Ben] Right after we
all washed our hands like.
- [Mark] The sacrifice
- [Bobby] No, no, no, I'll just have half.
- Next durian.
These little guys, these little
guys have impressive flavor.
(upbeat acoustic guitar
with keyboard music)
Mm, oh ho ho ho, wow.
I'm just gonna go ahead
and take a seat here.
I think I'm just gonna
move into this fruit stall.
(upbeat acoustic guitar music)
- [Mark] Smells like cheese, yeah.
- [Michael] Wood apple!
(bangs on wood apple)
- [Michael] It's good.
- [Mark] Oh yeah, there it is.
What is that one?
- This is honey
- [Mark] Oh, honey!
Wow.
- Palm honey
- [Mark] Palm honey.
(upbeat acoustic guitar music)
- [Michael] Honey bunny.
(Mark laughs)
- [Ben] Alright, you go first
- [Mark] (laughs) Yes!
- Mm, mm!
- [Mark] But the taste is awesome.
- [Michael] Good, good, good!
- [Mark] Yeah.
So another fruit that you have to eat when
you're in Sri Lanka is the wood apple.
And when I was in Sri
Lanka on my last trip
which was in like 2012 I believe.
No, it was like 2010!
But I remember eating wood apple on every
single day, every single occasion.
Just kinda scoops it into your hand.
Oh yes, that is the taste I remember.
It's pudding, it's like, it's
kinda like tamarinds to me.
Very sour, like mushy
because it's extra ripe.
And
It's just unique, it's a fruit
you gotta try, it's amazing.
And with that palm honey, pretty good.
- Cleaning the blood, yes.
cleaning the blood.
- [Mark] That's very good.
Thank you.
- [Michael] You make this the juice.
Very, very good.
- [Mark] Very nice.
- [Michael] You make the juice.
- You see last one, last one there.
- [Bobby] No, no, no.
- [Ben] No more, no more.
- Last one, last one, last
one, last one, last one.
- Oh, lamut!
- Sweet potato.
- [Ruzaina] Sweet potato?
- Yes.
- [Michael] That side.
- [Mark] Oh yeah, this one.
I forget the english name though.
- [Ben] It's like chiku, chiku.
- [Mark] Ying.
- Mm.
It's very very fruit, very,
very fruit, very, very sweet.
- Thank you very much.
- Have a good day.
- Okay, have a good day.
Okay, that was a completely impromptu
massive fruit buffet stop.
And we are back in the van.
Micah did you?
- Him, him, it measure up.
- [Ben] No, it's not him.
- Is it the
- [Ben] It's durian.
(laughs)
- I love it, poor Micah's
gonna get blamed for it.
(laughs)
- He said "Ya", I said " Did you?"
Then you're like nope, it's durian.
- Micah I'm very sorry for,
for blaming that on you.
I had forgotten already that
we had six durians in the back.
(laughs)
(Mridangam drum music)
(door opening)
Oh
Wow, ho ho ho.
(child talking)
We made it to Weligama after that
durian craziness and fruit buffet.
Checked into the hotel.
The view from the room is incredible!
We're gonna be staying here
for a couple of nights.
Have a little bit of time to relax.
And then we're gonna be going to dinner.
But, just, come check out this view.
Oh man, I didn't even know this was such a
surfing beach either.
How do you open it?
Open is up?
Oh, there we go.
Aw, oh the sound of the ocean, the waves.
Aw, tons of surfers out there.
(upbeat acoustic guitar music)
(waves rushing in)
For dinner tonight we're actually gonna be
eating on the beach, on
the sand at a restaurant.
Which was just 50 minute
drive down from the hotel.
The water is beautiful.
Sri Lanka is beautiful.
The coconut trees, the lapping waves.
It really is a beautiful, stunning island.
And we're getting ready to sit down
for seafood tonight for dinner.
- [Man] Food? I like that.
- [Sinan] Yeah. (laughs)
- [Mark] Here we go, don't hold back.
- [Abram] Oh yeah, yes!
- [Mark] Oh ho ho, nice.
Fried butter shrimp I believe.
Oh wow.
Aw, it's awesome.
Crispy.
Shrimpy.
Wonderful.
(clang of cutlery)
- [Mark] Yeah, yep, go for it.
- [Abram] Alright!
- [Mark] Delicious.
Fresh local tuna from Sri Lanka.
Oh wow.
Oh that's stunning, melt in your mouth.
Sesame seeds I think crusted
around it, really good.
(upbeat keyboard music)
- Delicious.
- How's your aunt?
- I'm loving life right now.
Put it right in front of me.
- [David] What is, what is?
- [Ruzaina] This is sluff potatoes
with stuffed with potatoe.
This is squid, this is a very local dish.
- [David] Ooh!
- [Ruzaina] You will
only get it from here.
- [David] Ooh!
- [Ruzaina] And he bought it
from a special place (mumbles)
Yeah he's from the southern side.
- (mumbles) it's like a mustard
and like vinegar mix, yeah.
So it's like a lot of onions and stuff.
- [Mark] Thank you, sir.
What's awesome about this place is that
he's serving us all
Southern Sri Lankan food.
So it's all from this region,
regional Sri Lankan food.
One of the dishes that
you'll only find in the south
is these stuffed squid which is from here.
Oh, wow.
Oh, that's amazing.
- Want fry bread?
- Oh, thank you!
- [Abram] What a beast.
- Tomatoey, mustardy
taste to it, really good.
And then the squid is so soft.
See some of that fish,
it's topped with onions.
You can see the turmeric on it.
It smells incredible and he
brought it over on a platter.
Oh, wow.
Oh.
Oh, what is that?
Oh yeah.
- [Ruzaina] Hadiya.
- [Mark] Now that looks good.
That looks awesome.
- [Ruzaina] Okay, so this is
This is a southern cutta sambal.
It's filled with mohda fish,
like it's a southern style.
This is the karawila.
This is very, very famous in Ceylon.
You know like we do whole
array of dry salted fish
with chilies and onions, look at that.
- [Mark] So it's kind of like a condiment
or it's a main dish?
- It's a condiment.
(laughs)
- Yes, look at this, yes!
- [Mark] It just never ends.
- Yes! Woo!
- What is it?
- I don't know but
- [Mark] But it looks incredible.
- [Abram] It looks tantalizing.
- Onions on that fish
they're just blooming.
Okay, just brought out a few more dishes
that we need to have immediately.
- [Abram] Oh man.
- [Mark] Oh, thank you.
I think it's almost like a relish,
you can see them onions in there,
you can see there's meat as well.
Oh.
It's like caramelized, oniony,
saltiness, chili, stunning.
- [Abram] Wow.
Oh, yep.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- [Abram] There we go.
- [Mark] Thank you guys.
- [Abram] Mm, yep!
- [Mark] Look at this prawn,
look at that curry sauce.
The curry sauce is just
juicing into the prawn.
I'll come back for the head later.
Ho ho ho, look at that!
Oh, the thickness of that!
- [Sinan] I think that's the first time
that David's eaten something spicy.
- Oh wow.
- [Ruzaina] Thank you.
- Oh that prawn, it's incredible.
- [Abram] Food is amazing.
- It's so meaty, it's so muscular.
Mm, mm!
Dude, are you re-saucing me?
- [Abram] Yeah.
- [Mark] Thank you, okay.
- [Abram] Look at that.
- [Mark] Oh ho ho ho ho ho ho.
- [Sinan] I've never heard
"Are you re-saucing me?"
(Mark laughs)
- That's a true friend.
- [Sinan] Dunkage please?
Dunkage?
- That's a
- [David] Just dunk here.
- That is a true friend, a true friend.
- [Abram] Just getting better here.
(laughs)
- Thank you.
- [Abram] Oh yeah.
- Mm.
Oh.
Dude.
I wanna shower in that sauce.
(laughter)
Part of the reason this meal is so
much fun is because of
everybody that's here.
- Yeah!
- [Mark] (mumbles) The
Bedouin Foodie, Sinan, David
- [David] Look at my hands.
- [Mark] Abram, Ruzaina.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Eating with good people
makes the food even better.
But the food is, yeah, the
food is unbelievably good.
(laughter)
- [David] No, hey, wait, wait
- Wait, wait, wait.
Put these guys there.
- [Mark] These guys are going
delirious from the food.
- [David] This is gonna
be the best, okay guys!
- [Abram] I'm taking
some of that right here.
- [David] Guys, guys, go ahead.
- [Ruzaina] Oh wow.
- Cheers. (laughs)
- Yeah.
It's just stunning.
Mm.
I'm covered in spice.
Oh, that is ridiculously good.
Oh ho ho ho ho ho.
- [Ruzaina] Oh wow.
- [Mark] Out of control.
(Hoots)
- [Mark] Oh, that, wow.
- [Abram] Yes!
That looks deep!
(laughs)
Yeah!
- [Mark] Should we check the depth?
(laughs)
- [Abram] It's about two
centimeters, it's deep.
- [Sinan] Oh!
- Oh shi- (laughs)
I'm goin right for the money.
- I'm going for this, look at this.
This looks like friendly.
- [Mark] How is it, Sinan?
- It's unbelievably good.
It's delicious.
(laughs)
- Ready?
- [Mark] A boneless drumstick.
- [Ruzaina] Wow!
- [David] Mark, I want
to dedicate this for you.
- [Mark] Boneless drumstick.
- Dedication for Mark.
- [Mark] Oh, thank you.
- It looks appropriate, look at this.
And then you could take
more of the juice here.
Look at it, mm, mm, mm, mm.
(upbeat keyboard music)
- [Mark] Thank you, David.
- [Abram] Wow, people around
us must think we're animals.
(laughs)
- [Mark] This is after we've eaten like
20 plates of other food already.
We're just all like in a
different state of mind.
We're seeing things, we're
not thinking straight.
And it is ama-, the food
is unbelievably good.
The crab, oh wow.
- 'Cause I love you.
- [Mark] The spoon.
(laughs)
Oh wow.
Oh ho ho ho ho, wow.
Oh that sauce, oh the curry leaves.
Oh, oh, I'm just gonna leave
that on my chin for later.
Oh!
(laughs)
- [Mark] It's almost
too much, look at this.
Oh nice to meet you!
(laughs)
- [David] 'Kay it's nothing, it's nothing.
It's just pure crab meat there.
- [Mark] Oh, that sauce!
Got the claw fully sauced,
dripping in juices.
- [Abram] We do the straggler.
- Oh wow.
That is, it's actually stunning.
Mind-blowing.
- [Mark] We just finished with that meal.
That was at Zephyr restaurant.
A little bit south, I
believe, of Weligama.
And we went into that meal,
I honestly had no idea what to expect.
It's on the beach, it's
a beautiful location.
And all the dishes that we've
had were actually off-menu.
That's special order, locally prepared.
Those are all Southern Sri Lankan,
specifically Southern
Sri Lankan dishes and
that was an unbelievable meal.
I still can't hardly even comprehend
how delicious that food was.
I want to say a massive thank you
to David, The Hungry Tourist,
on the Best of Sri Lanka tour.
And Ruzaina and Uchith and Nick
and Laki for arranging everything.
This has been a spectacular day.
And again, I had no idea what
to expect, but what a day.
I'm actually kinda sore in my shoulder
from all of that crab eating.
It was just, things got
a little out of control.
A huge thank you for watching this video.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up if you enjoyed it.
Leave a comment below,
I'd love to hear from you.
And if you're not already
subscribed, click subscribe now.
And also click the little
bell icon so that you
can get notified of the
next video that I publish.
Thanks again for watching.
Good bye from Weligama, Sri Lanka.
See you on the next video!